[Music]
that's the cast of encanto giving the
academy awards something to talk about
with their first live performance of we
don't talk about bruno
[Music]
while becky g and luis fonsi were
previously announced to join the
ensemble megan the stallion made a
surprise appearance
every day all the kids want to hear his
bro
he's a new letting go all my cards in
you see what you have done on
hollywood's biggest night better
cinematic
[Music]
i was a little nervous before i went out
there because i've never been to the
oscars before so i was like i just want
to be great it feels like yeah i did
that now what
encantos filmmakers already celebrating
their win for best animated feature said
they too were shocked by the rapper's
cameo they kept a lot of secrets from us
we knew that there was going to be some
version of bruno tonight but it was
going to be something unexpected and fun
so seeing meghan italian do it is
mind-blowing absolutely mind-blowing
disney's chart-topper wasn't nominated
for an oscar with producers deciding to
submit dostorugitas for best original
song hamilton's lin-manuel miranda
penned all eight songs on encanto's
soundtrack he previously joked to e.t
about the earworm becoming a phenomenon
who is the most famous person who's
texted you and said i can't get this
song out of my head
i'll tell you the first person i got a
dm from taika with td
and he was the first one that was like
it's constant with my kids it's constant
right now i love you but i might hate
you soon
we've surpassed frozen and let it go
it's it's well not in our hearts um i
love let it go but we're it's um it's
really amazing that that's the song that
connected i'm like thrilled and
surprised every day encanto is being
praised for its celebration of diversity
the cast says the musical is an
important moment for the latinx
community it's just a moment that lasts
us for a very long time and i hope that
this is the beacon that we crack the
door open for more of this leading up to
the big night encantos carolina gaitan
said there's a special meaning behind
the performance it's crazy it's surreal
it's magical realism
it's just something that i cannot
explain i am like oh my god this is
crazy but of course it's ah
so many things involved as well and
behind and are
i think it's the message behind the song
and it's why we don't talk about some
people on specific
in our families in the society
we definitely have
something to tell more than a fun stone
it's through inclusion as well we
sometimes
cannot understand some people and then
we decide not to talk about them so this
is about inclusion definitely
you